من المؤكد ان الكثير منا يصيبهم القلق انت
بصيغه القلق ابدا خصوصا اذا ما جاءتهم
رساله واتساب من رقم مجهول الهويه بتقلق
مزعج هذا القلق عدد ربما
يتبدد قريبا مع احاديث عن ميزه جديده من
التطبيق او في التطبيق الاخضر تتيح كتابه
اسم المستخدم بدلا من الرقم يروى طبعا هذا
التحديث الضخم من شانه ان يمنح المزيد من
الخ
صوص حيث سيسمح
بالحاجه لتسجيل ارقام هواتفهم مسبقا كذلك
فان الامر سيكون سهلا لتذكر الاسماء دون
الحاجه لتذكر الارقام التي عاده ما تكون
اصعب بكثير هذا الميزه الجديده قيد
التجارب لكن بمجرد الحديث عنها بدات ردود
الفعل الايجابيه التي تدعم هذه الفتره
ويبحث التطبيق مشاهدينا عن زياده الثقه به
واستحاله المنافسه الشديده التي يشهدها من
تطبيقات اخرى ممثله
[موسيقى]
الينا من عمان رائد سموره خبير امن
المعلومات اتمنى اني انا نطقت الاسم صحيح
كما وصلني ولا
ما شاء الله عليك يسعد صباحك كل اسمك
دائما جميل شكرا جزيلا استاذ رائد خليني
اسال بانه اليوم هذه الميزه دائما ما نسمع
انه ستاخذ فتره طويله هل هي كشف خصوصيه من
وين تدخل من الممكن انه تحل قصه الازعاج
ولا راح تاثر على اشياء اخرى
والله انا سمعتك وانت تحكي على لما سالتك
الاستاذ راويه هل انت قلق الحقيقه انا قلق
مش انت ليه
الموضوع بيروح باتجاه مختلف تماما لانه
علمتنا التجارب اذا منصات التواصل اكثر من
منصه تبنى الذات الخاصيه وهناك منصات اخرى
تويتر مثلا سوف يتبنى ذاته الخاصيه
معناه في هناك بعد امني في هذه المساله
وليست من مصلحه فقط مش من مصلحه في
المستخدم كمستخدم وانما من مصلحه تلك
المنصات ومن شغل تلك المنصه هذه هذه هذا
الجانب الاول اللي يثير لدي القلق في هذه
المساله استاذ رائد احكي لنا فيما يخص
تحديث واتساب تحديدا شو الاشي اللي
بيشكل لك قلق فيه معلش الكهف والقاف دخلوا
على بعض فهمت علي شو قلقان
القلق من لا يمكن اني افصل الحاله عن
تطبيقات ثانيه لكن لكن الان في طبقه جديده
من طبقات خلينا زي ما سماها واتساب من
طبقات الحمايه للمستخدم من خلال يوزر نيم
الان هذا اليوزر نيم سوف يكون يعني
سوف يكون بشكل خاص لصاحب هذا الحساب لكن
لا تستطيع انت ان تفتح اي حساب على
الواتساب بدون رقم هاتف يعني مش لا يمكن
انك تيجي مباشره تفتح واتساب وتدخل
وتقول له انا ارغب بهذا اليوزر نيم لا
لازم اول يتوسط الحساب على رقم الهاتف ومن
ثم تحصل على يوزر نيم اذا انا في كلتا
الحالتين واخذ مني رقم الهاتف واخذ مني
ايضا يوزر نيم معناه تتبع اللي الي حيكون
تتبع مثالي من خلال قناتين مرتبطتين مع
بعضهما البعض ما هي ما هي يعني ما هي
استفاده
اذا اردنا ان نسيء الظن يعني من الممكن
انه يكون حمايه اكثر ليش ناخذها انه ممكن
يستفيد يبيع المعلومات الى اخره
فينا استاذي عندما نتعامل مع منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي ان نتعامل معها
لا لا مش ما في شيء ببلاش
مبنيه على خوارزميات هذا واحد اثنين وتساب
تحديدا الان انتهت نوعين من انواع
الحسابات اللي هو البزنس واللي هو الان
انا اعتقد انه اليوزر نيم تحديدا سوف يكون
بشكل اكبر للبزنس للاسماء التجاريه وانه
هذا الامر سوف يخضع في ساعه من الساعات
الى رسوم بمعنى كيف الدومين نيم كيف انت
بتشتري دومين نيم دبليو دبليو دبليو دوت
مثلا العربيه دوت نت او دوت كوم بدك تصير
تشتري هذا الاسم مثلا اترا اتسموه على
واتساب هذا خلاص حصري بصير ادفع عليه انا
سنويا
رسوم معينه وهذا هون بدا البزنس وهون بدا
العمل
معلش انت قلقتنا هيك اكثر يعني بس
ما باليد حيلها زي ما بقولوا شكرا جزيلا
لك من عمان رائد سمور خبير امن الم
علومات لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات